all right onside kicks here we go you
hate fourth and 15
and there are enough people in the nfl
that don't want to do fourth and 15 and
just
quick background right in lieu of the
onside kick which is now almost
impossible to recover
there has been a proposal for the past
few years two
allow the team that's trailing under
certain circumstances
to attempt a fourth and fifteen play if
they convert they keep possession
there are issues with that chris you've
done a good job of articulating in the
past for example if you have patrick
mahomes you gotta defend the whole field
you get a touchdown because you're
worried about defending the 15-yard line
that the team has to get to to keep
possession so
in an effort to stave that off they have
limited the total number of players on
the receiving team
that can line up in the setup zone 10 to
25 yards
from the point of the kick maximum of
nine
typical onside kick there's 10 or 11
in the setup zone now the most you can
have
is nine players there and it's just
numbers
it's numbers if you only have nine and
the kicking team has 11
maybe there's a better chance the
kicking team's gonna recover the onside
kick chris
yeah i mean listen this is a it's a nice
adjustment there's no doubt about that
i i mean uh it do i do think it
increases the chances a little but i
don't know
by how much right mike i mean that's
that's going to be the big question
you know we're talking about again i
think the biggest thing here
more than anything with the onside kicks
is just the current setup of what we
have with
guys having to line up like you see in
this picture
right where the ball is being kicked and
not being able to give enough time
and everything like that to where now
the the
the the kicker can't kick those balls
that you know two hops on the ground
and hit the big hop in the air right
that has gone away so we've had to
adjust all that so
hey yes i like this adjustment i think
it's cool to tinker with a little bit
um but i don't know mike in my heart of
hearts if i really think it's going to
make a huge difference in the approach
of how this works because to me the
problem
here with the unfairness is not about
how many
players the receiving team has in the
box it's really more about the setup of
the kickoff in general and i understand
we're doing things there for player
safety
and i'm all for that but it's just
really hard with the mechanics for the
kicking team right now
to recover that ball with guys starting
right even with the football
and it doesn't give them a chance to get
to the 10-yard mark
and make a play on the ball so again i'm
all for this i like this i'm not gonna
you know uh kick back or i mean or
or get mad about this i'm all for it but
i just think that
i don't know if it's going to have much
of a change on the game itself
yeah the key change to the to the entire
kickoff play that
affected the ability to recover the
onside kick the elimination of the
running start
yeah now all those players are lined up
they're starting from flat feet
starting without momentum to get to that
10 yard
mark faster that's the point you're
making yeah and now the kicker can't
kick down it before they do
right exactly the kicker can't kick that
ball that we used to see where it was
like
two little skips on the ground and then
all of a sudden it pops up in the air 15
feet in the air
and that's when the kicking team had a
chance because now they've had that
running start
and okay yeah the kicker kicked it
perfectly like 14 yards down the field
and we can get there as the ball is
coming down
and have a 50 50 chance with the
receiving team
but this is the only thing we've seen be
successful
i mean this is it right here is and we
saw this what
twice in one game you know so it's just
so
rare at this point i mean these are the
most
well executed onsite kicks these are
what all this is and this wasn't really
come on this was just dumb i don't know
what that was all right
by the falcons but either way i mean
that's
for everybody out there that's all the
onside kicks covered
in the last year that was all of them
right and that might have been one from
even the year before that am i
right so there was three last year total
that was the one from the year
before and so i i mean again i'm all for
it
i just don't i don't know mike i don't
know if it's really going to matter here
i don't roger goodell said years ago
when he was asked who he roots for i
root for the team that's trailing the
league really wants
the team that's trailing by multiple
scores to have a chance to get back in
the game and when the onside kick
can't be recovered at a sufficiently
high rate
you look for other alternatives that
will change those numbers and we'll see
over the course of the next year or two
whether or not to what extent
this change will increase the success
rate for the recovery the onside kick
now it is a very dangerous play
yeah there was a time 20 years or so ago
when
they were taking away the mulligan that
you used to get right you kicked it out
of bounds
you used another chance to do it yeah
and bill cower i'm told was a very
staunch proponent he called it a courage
drill this was something that measured
toughness in players
because you were literally in car
crashes
across the board whoa right and that's
one of the reasons they're trying to
make the game safer because you get
concussions you get other injuries that
happen during that
but then you you don't have an
opportunity to recover an onside kick
that's
the problem that's the challenge and
that's the the balance the nfl is trying
to strike and
i think they'll try this chris and if it
doesn't work
that's when we're going to see fourth
and 15. yeah whether
it has flaws or it doesn't and it does
have flaws look i i think if they go
fourth and 15 onside kicks right
they should just go fourth and 15
kickoff period and punt
if you're normally going to punt that's
your kickoff yeah and then you can run a
fake out of there that's your surprise
onside kick
or you can just line your quarterback up
under center and go for it which would
be
the simulation of the planned on
sidekick but i still like that
unpredictability of the surprise onside
kick
and if you do a straight fourth and 15
play and it's only when you're trailing
by a certain number of points and
everyone knows you're going to go for it
you never have a surprise onside kick if
you do that no
no you you you don't you're right you
know nicole can you
like bring up that first picture with
the alignment
you know and then take your time i know
i'm calling on the fly here
but you know here's listen really
as an ex football player a guy who loves
the game everything like that i wish
they could go back to finding a way to
where
we don't have to have the courage drill
right anymore
to where we could find a way to go back
to let the kicking team
have the running start the the kicker
could kick the ball
the way he used to and find a way to
have rules about
you know limited contact something like
that
i would rather it see it go that way
than all these other alternatives
you know you see the setup zone here and
all this stuff
okay so now let's just say one guy is
taken out of this right like we're
talking about so
for for this for the sake of this i mean
okay buffalo right now this is buffalo
in the afc championship game right
what is kansas city going to do from
this setup what maybe take
one guy maybe at the top of the screen
who's on the 49 yard line or 40
and what put him behind the yellow line
i mean we already know which way the
ball is being kicked here
right so that's where i go i don't know
if it really changes anything
and okay so now you're going to make
that guy let's just say that guy at the
top of the screen at the 48 yard line
you're going to move him beyond that
yellow line is there any rule to where
you can move him
like if i'm that team now if i'm kansas
city that guy at the top of the screen
in the 48-yard line
i'm gonna move him to the zero on the
40-yard line down here at the bottom
and as soon as the ball gets kicked i'm
gonna tell him to run up there
and be a part of it so that's where i
don't know if it's really going to have
a great
change that was the first thing that
jumped out to me when i kind of read the
rule i went well
these these special teams coaches are
just going to move these guys back and
be out of the zone
but as soon as the ball gets kicked
they're gonna go up and make a play and
because of the current state of how this
is set up too
like we see buffalo's kicking the ball
down here
and the way it it works now you can't
even do the fake like hey i'm gonna kick
it this way
and now kick it back the other way
because you guys have too many guys on
one
side or you're overloaded in one area so
that's gone too so i just that's where i
go i don't know if this is really gonna
have any effect on the situation tell me
if you thought that had any logic or
brains to it at all
it it makes sense but i think you're
talking about the chiefs player who is
standing right near the zero on the
fifth
yeah top of the screen right you take
that guy yeah right
and you move him to the other side of
the field so he can
run up right crash into that that group
that's
scrambling for the ball then you've got
a potential imbalance of numbers on the
top so
couldn't you then if you have to take
that guy and move him down
on the other side of the yellow line
couldn't you then
run up to the ball and like kick it with
your heel back up
i and you have that one fewer guy up
there i know that's something you could
do to counter that
that's what i was that's what i was
saying like because now we have these
guys like starting at the dead stop
right where the ball is kicked off
and because the way you know you have to
kick it now
it's hard for the kicker to kind of
trick people like he used to in the back
day you know what i'm saying that's what
i was trying to say because the way
that's set up
yeah back in the old day they'd go whoa
there are there's too many guys over
there i'm gonna act like i'm gonna kick
it over there and then like you're
saying right
do the old back kick or sidekick and
they kick it the other way
and the numbers match up and i it's hard
it seems harder to do and we certainly
haven't seen it
ever since they set it up this way and
if we have it's been very limited times
and i don't remember
there's a reality to this that
that will entail the special teams
coordinators now brainstorming
exactly ways to to to try to recover
this and
the special teams coordinators have been
instrumental in saving the kickoff
in its current form they had the ideas a
few years ago that made it a safer play
and hey you take away the onside kick
that's just one less thing that the
special teams coordinator has influence
over because then it goes back to
offense and defense for the fourth and
15th play
so this is the hail mary effort by
special teams coordinators and the hail
mary effort by the league
to fend off the fourth and 15 because
i i i sense that your concerns about
fourth and 15
are shared by others in the league and
they don't want to cross that bridge
until they have
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports